a commencé quand McDonald's a accepté un partenariat
avec le Fonds de défense de l'environnement.
C'était une ONG
fondée sur le principe de « poursuivre ces cons en justice ».
Je me demandais
ce qu'ils pensaient de moi et de mon équipe.
La première fois que j'ai rencontré Richard Denison,
le scientifique principal pour le FDE,
j'étais très inquiet.
Je pensais que c'était un hippie
et je pensais qu'il pensait que tout ce qui m'importait était l'argent.
Nous voulions que l'équipe du FDE nous donne des solutions réalistes.
Nous avons fait ce qui était logique :
nous les avons fait tourner des steaks dans nos restaurants.
Vous devez imaginer Richard
qui, au passage, a un doctorat de physique,
et le voilà à essayer de préparer un hamburger.
Vous êtes censés y mettre deux giclées de ketchup, une de moutarde,
trois cornichons, un oignon et passer au suivant,
vous devez être très rapide.
Vous savez quoi ? Il n'a pas réussi de la journée.
Il était frustré.
J'étais très impressionné
car il essayait de comprendre ce que nous faisions.
L'équipe du FDE
pensait que des emballages réutilisables étaient le Graal pour notre entreprise.
Mon équipe et moi pensions : « Des emballages réutilisables ?
Trop de place, ce serait le bordel,
ils nous ralentiraient. »
Mais nous n'avons pas rejeté l'idée.
Nous sommes allés dans l'arrière-salle
du restaurant qu'ils avaient choisi près de Washington,
Le lave-vaisselle ne fonctionnait pas bien,
il recrachait de la vaisselle sale.
La cuisine était encrassée et sale.
Comparé à leur expérience
dans un McDonald's qui était propre et organisé,
ils pouvaient voir la différence frappante.
Nous avons passé toute une journée assis dans un McDonald's
et avons regardé les clients manger.
Leur comportement.
Il s'est avéré que de nombreux clients partaient avec leur nourriture,
leur boisson.
Le FDE a conclu de lui-même
que des emballages réutilisables ne marcheraient pas pour nous.
Mais ils ont eu de nombreuses idées qui ont fonctionné.
Nous n'y aurions jamais pensé de nous-mêmes,
sans l'équipe du FDE.
Ma préférée était de passer du sac en papier blanc
au sac en papier marron.
Nous utilisions le sac blanc.
C'est un matériau vierge,
il est fait grâce à un blanchiment au chlore
et ils nous ont dit d'utiliser un sac non blanchi,
sans produits chimiques.
Il est fait de matériaux recyclés,
principalement d'emballages d'expédition ondulés.
Il s'avère que le sac est plus résistant, la fibre est plus solide,
cela ne nous a pas coûté plus d'argent.
C'était gagnant-gagnant.
Une autre idée qu'ils ont eue
était que nous pouvions raccourcir notre serviette de trois centimètres.
Et qu'elle soit faite à partir de papier recyclé.
J'ai pensé que trois centimètres, cela importait peu.
Nous l'avons fait et réduit nos déchets de 1,5 million de kilos par an.
16 000 arbres sauvés.
(Applaudissements)
Ce qui était cool,
c'est que nous avons changé cette serviette d'un blanc éclatant
car le contenu recyclé est devenu gris et moucheté.
Et cela est devenu
dans l'air du temps, en vogue chez les clients.
J'en suis venu à vraiment apprécier
le temps passé à travailler avec l'équipe du FDE.
Nous avons eu des dîners, des conversations tardives,
avons été voir un match ensemble.
Nous sommes devenus amis.
C'est là que j'ai appris une leçon de vie.
Ces militants d'ONG,
ils n'étaient pas différents de moi.
Ils tenaient à quelque chose, étaient passionnés,
nous n'étions pas différents.
Nous avons eu un partenariat de six mois
qui a généré un plan avec 42 actions de réduction des déchets.
Pour réduire, réutiliser, recycler.
Nous avons mesuré cela au cours des années 90 :
en 10 ans, nous avons réduit nos déchets de 150 millions de kilos de déchets.
Si vous vous posez des questions au sujet de cette boîte en polystyrène,
nous l'avons laissé tomber.
Heureusement, j'avais encore un emploi.
Ce partenariat a été une telle réussite
que nous avons recyclé l'idée de travailler avec des critiques.
De collaborer avec eux sur des solutions pouvant marcher
pour la société et les affaires.
Mais cette idée de collaboration
pourrait-elle fonctionner avec les gens les plus anticonformistes ?
Et sur des problèmes qui sont hors de notre contrôle direct ?
Comme les droits des animaux.
Les droits des animaux :
pas d'animaux utilisés pour de la viande.
McDonald's : probablement le plus gros acheteur de viande
de l'industrie alimentaire.
Il y a là un conflit naturel.
Mais j'ai pensé que le mieux
serait d'aller les voir
et d'apprendre des critiques les plus véhéments et vigilants
que nous avions à l'époque
et qui étaient Henry Spira, le fondateur de Animal Rights International,
et Peter Singer,
qui a écrit le livre « La libération animale »
qui est considéré comme le traité moderne sur les droits des animaux.
J'ai lu le livre de Peter afin de me préparer,
j'ai essayé d'adopter son état d'esprit
et je dois l'admettre, c'était difficile,
je ne deviendrai pas végétalien,
mon entreprise ne disparaîtra pas.
Mais nous pouvions beaucoup en apprendre.
J'ai organisé un petit-déjeuner de travail à New York.
Je me souviens m'être assis, me préparer
et décider de ne pas commander ce que je préfère :
du bacon, des saucisses et des œufs.
(Rires)
J'allais m'en tenir aux pâtisseries.
Mais je dois admettre
que je m'attendais à ce que la conversation conflictuelle arrive.
Elle n'est jamais arrivée.
Henry et Peter ont été courtois,
ils ont été bienveillants, intelligents, ils ont posé les bonnes questions.
Je leur ai dit combien travailler sur le bien-être animal
était difficile pour McDonald's
car nos fournisseurs directs font uniquement des steaks hachés.
Les animaux sont trois ou quatre étapes au-delà de notre influence.
Ils ont été très empathiques.
Et alors que nous étions en opposition si directe
en termes de mission de nos organisations,
j'ai beaucoup appris.
Et le meilleur, c'est qu'ils m'ont donné une formidable recommandation.
Ils ont dit :
« Vous devriez travailler avec le Dr Temple Grandin. »
A l'époque, je ne la connaissais pas.
Mais je peux vous dire
que c'est l'experte la plus renommée, à l'époque et aujourd'hui,
en comportement animal.
Elle sait comment les animaux se déplacent et comment ils devraient réagir.
J'ai fini par la rencontrer
et elle fait partie du meilleur genre de critiques :
elle adore les animaux,
elle veut les protéger,
mais elle comprend également la réalité de l'industrie de la viande.
Je me souviendrai toujours,
je n'avais jamais été dans un abattoir de ma vie
et j'y suis allé avec elle pour ma première fois.
Je ne savais pas à quoi m'attendre.
Nous avons découvert
que les responsables avaient des pistolets à impulsion électrique en main
et électrocutaient les animaux au sein de l'établissement.
Nous avons tous les deux été horrifiés, elle faisait des bonds -
vous devriez la connaître -
elle disait : « Impossible, cela ne va pas,
nous pourrions utiliser des drapeaux, des sacs,
reconcevoir les corrals pour un comportement naturel. »
J'ai mis Temple en contact avec nos fournisseurs
pour établir des standards et des directives.
Ainsi que des façons de mesurer ses idées pour mettre en œuvre le bien-être animal.
Nous l'avons fait pendant les cinq années qui ont suivi.
Tout cela a été intégré et mis en œuvre.
Deux fournisseurs nous ont perdu comme client
car ils ne répondaient pas à nos exigences.
Le meilleur :
tous ces standards se sont étendus à l'industrie tout entière.
Ces animaux ne sont plus électrocutés.
Qu'en est-il des problèmes dont on nous accuse ailleurs ?
Comme la déforestation.
Sur ce sujet, j'ai toujours pensé
que c'était le rôle des décideurs politiques et du gouvernement.
Je n'ai jamais pensé que cela me retomberait dessus.
Mais je me souviens, début avril 2006,
j'ai allumé mon Blackberry
et j'ai lu au sujet de militants de Greenpeace
au Royaume-Uni, se pointant par dizaines, déguisés en poules,
prenant leur petit-déjeuner à McDonald's
et s'enchaînant aux chaises et aux tables.
Ils ont obtenu beaucoup d'attention,
y compris la mienne.
Je me demandais si le rapport qu'ils venaient de publier,
qui s'appelait « Manger l'Amazonie » --
le soja est un ingrédient clé de la nourriture des poules
et c'est cela le lien avec McDonald's.
J'ai appelé mes amis de confiance du Fonds mondial pour la nature,
j'ai appelé Conservation International
et j'ai vite appris que le rapport de Greenpeace était exact.
J'ai recueilli du soutien interne
et je me souviendrai toujours le lendemain de la campagne,
je les ai appelés
et j'ai dit : « Nous sommes d'accord avec vous. »
J'ai dit : « Et si nous travaillions ensemble ? »
Trois jours plus tard,
miraculeusement, quatre personnes de McDonald's,
quatre personnes de Greenpeace,
nous nous réunissons à l'aéroport de Londres Heathrow.
Je dois dire que la première heure a été hésitante,
il n'y avait pas beaucoup de confiance dans la pièce.
Mais il semble que tout s'est mis en place
car chacun d'entre nous voulait sauver l'Amazonie.
Durant nos discussions,
je ne crois pas que vous pouviez dire
qui était de Greenpeace et qui était de McDonald's.
L'une des meilleures choses que nous avons faites
a été de voyager avec eux durant neuf jours à travers l'Amazonie
dans l'avion de Greenpeace et sur le bateau de Greenpeace.
Je m'en souviendrai toujours :
imaginez voyager des centaines de kilomètres à l'ouest de Manaus,
la capitale de l'Amazonie.
Sa beauté est si virginale,
il n'y a pas de structures humaines, il n'y a pas de routes,
pas un seul câble, pas une seule maison.
Si vous voyagiez à l'est de Manaus,
vous verriez la destruction manifeste de la forêt tropicale.
Cette collaboration très improbable a abouti à des résultats extraordinaires.
En travaillant ensemble,
nous avons recruté une dizaine d'entreprises et leurs fournisseurs
pour la même cause.
Au passage, en l'espace de trois mois,
un moratoire sur ces pratiques de coupe des forêts
a été annoncé par l'industrie.
Greenpeace a même déclaré une chute spectaculaire de la déforestation
et cela est en vigueur depuis.
Vous penseriez que ce genre de collaborations que j'ai décrites
serait aujourd'hui courant.
Mais ce n'est pas le cas.
Quand les organisations sont malmenées,
la réponse habituelle est de nier et de rejeter les allégations,
de publier une sorte de déclaration boiteuse
et aucun progrès n'est réalisé.
Je dis que l'alternative est formidable.
Cela ne va pas résoudre tous les problèmes
et il y a certainement plus à faire,
mais cette idée de travailler avec nos critiques
et d'essayer d'accomplir plus de bien pour la société,
c'est bon pour les affaires,
croyez-moi, c'est possible.
Mais cela commence par l'idée
que vous devez présumer que vos critiques ont les meilleures intentions possibles.
Tout comme vous avez les meilleures intentions possibles.
Deuxièmement,
vous devez aller au-delà de ces tactiques.
Je l'admets, je n'aimais pas nombre des tactiques
employées par mon entreprise.
Au lieu de cela, concentrez-vous sur la vérité,
sur la meilleure chose à faire,
sur la science, sur les faits.
Pour finir, je dirais :
donnez les clés aux critiques.
Montrez-leur l'arrière-salle.
Amenez-les-y, ne cachez pas les détails
car si vous voulez des alliés et du soutien,
vous devez être ouverts et transparents.
Que vous soyez un décideur dans une entreprise,
que vous voyez un écolo,
la prochaine fois que vous êtes critiqué,
contactez la personne, écoutez, apprenez.
Vous deviendrez meilleur, votre organisation deviendra meilleure
et vous pourriez vous faire de bons amis en chemin.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)